[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
pour cette nouvelle édition de
présidentielle 360 voici les titres
manuel Vals va-t-il se rallier Emmanuel
Macron l'ancien Premier ministre réunit
ses soutiens à l'Assemblée nationale il
hésite toujours sur la ligne à adopter
après avoir renoncé à parener Benoît
Hamont nous serons direct du Palais
Bourbon dans un instant Pénélope Fillon
attendu chez les magistrats risque à son
tour une mise en examen pendant ce temps
les fionionistes poursuivent l'offensive
sur le cabinet noir mais qu'en est-il
exactement sur quoi se fonde cette
accusation pourquoi les affaires sortent
en période électorale on ouvre le débat
dans cette édition le docteur Michel
Aubier cité à comparaître pour parjure
devant le Sénat le pneumologue avait
caché ses liens avec total lors de son
audition sous serment par une commission
d'enquête sénatorial l'audience doit
avoir lieu le 14 juin prochain devant le
tribunal correctionnel de Paris et je
vous rappelle que vous pouvez réagir en
direct sur Twitter
hprésidentiel 360 pour m'accompagner cet
après-midi Saveria rojc et amtranit le
multiplex c'est tout de
[Musique]
suite je vous le disais en titre l'heure
du choix pour Manuel Vals le perdant de
la primaire socialiste rencontre une
nouvelle ses soutiens à l'Assemblée
nationale il y a 15 jours il avait
annoncé qu'il refusait de pariner Benoît
hont va-t-il pour autant annoncer son
ralliment Emmanuel Macron rien n'est
moins sûr il sait qu'il n'est pas le
bienvenu alors pour en parler on va tout
de suite retrouver en direct de
l'Assemblée national Saveria Roget
qu'est-ce que la réunion a débuté est-ce
qu'on sait un peu plus et bien le choix
de Manuel
Vals absolument Delphine la réunion a
débuté le choix de Manuel Vals non pas
encore mais en tout cas on a pu voir
arriver Élisabeth Guigou Claude
Bartelone les ministres Jean-Jacques
curvoise Juliette Méadel ou encore les
sénateur Didier Guillaume Michel André
et Jean-Pierre sur alors l'objectif de
cette réunion c'est bien de trancher
pour ou contre un éventuel soutien à
Emmanuel Macron après un déjeuner tout à
l'heure vous l'avez dit au Sénat
l'ancien Premier ministre a réuni ses
troupes ici à l'Assemblée chez les vacis
il y a deux camps ceux qui prônent un
ralliment avant le premier tour et les
autres qui préfèrent rester neutes
d'après nos informations manuel Vass
n'aurait pas encore tranché il est
prudent son objectif bien sûr c'est de
conserver ces trous pour l'après
présidentielle équation compliquée pour
Manuel Val sur le fond les désaccords
sont actés avec Benoît amont mais
comment soutenir Emmanuel Macron sans
donner le sentiment de se rallier ou
encore même de se vendre et surtout
comment peser dans la future majorité
certains poursent à une rupture rapide
hein c'est le cas du député Malec Bouti
qui veut un soutien avant avant même le
premier tour d'autres au contraire
penchent plus pour la discrétion et là
c'est le cas de plusieurs ministres pour
qu' le moment n'est pas encore venu leur
argument Emmanuel Macron n'a pas besoin
de renfort maintenant Emmanuel Macron
qui dit lui vouloir Delphine être le
maître des horloge merci beaucoup
savriien pour vos précisions et Benoît
amamont était quant à lui à Berlin où il
a rencontré Angela Merkel il a exposé à
la chancellère allemande sa ses
divergence notamment sur la question des
déficits en revanche et vous le voyez
sur ces images il a reçu le soutien du
chef de fil du SPD Martin Schulz à
l'issue d'une rencontre entre les deux
hommes Benoist amont a rappelé la
bataille qu'il menait ensemble contre
l'extrême droite on
l'écoute il y a une singularité dans le
débat politique français qui je crois
préoccupe
légitimement beaucoup de dirigeants
allemands tout particulièrement les les
dirigeants socio-démocrates allemands
c'est le poids de l'extrême droite le
risque que le vote Le Pen ferait peser
sur l'avenir de la France et donc la
place de la France dans l'Europe et donc
le projet européen ce vote est lié au
maintien ou à la poursuite de politique
d'austérité en Europe et moi je
considère que l'austérité est un dogme
et comme tous les dogmes les dogmes
échappent à la raison et quand on
poursuit des politiques d'austérité on
prend le risque d raisonnable et bien de
fabriquer des réponses politiques qui
risquent d'ensevelir le projet européen
quatre candidats à la présidentielle sur
le grill des patrons Emmanuel Macron
marine Le Pen François Fillon et Jacques
Cheminade ont été auditionnés sur leurs
programmes économiques par le MDEF les
chefs d'entreprise inquiets d'une
éventuelle sortie de l'euro Cécile Sixou
Madame Le Pen bonjour c'est une première
Marine Le Pen invitée à la table des
patron pour présenter son programme
économique bien monsieur le Président
qui n'est pas là je crois mais qui ne va
pas tarder beaucoup sur ces notes sur la
défensive la présidente du FN n'était
pas en terrain conquis croyez-vous
Madame Le Pen que la sortie de l'
soit la meilleure méthode pour créer la
confiance d'abord que mes propos soient
bien compris ce sont les Français qui
vont décider c'est clair moi je vais
aller élu présidente de la République
engager une négociation avec l'Union
européenne parce qu'on voit bien qu'il y
a toute une série de choses quand même
qui ne fonctionnent pas et que notre
économie aujourd'hui est au bord de
l'asphyxie François Fillon lui a eu le
droit à une séance photo avec le patron
du
Medef ici le candidat LR est loin des
affaires plus applaudi que les autres
par les représentants des patrons
notamment sur ces propositions de baisse
des charges des entreprises mais aussi
des dépenses publiques de 100 milliards
d'euros son programme est de loin le
plus séduisant pour Pierre gataz le
président du meddeef un programme
économique de François Fillon économique
et social qui a une vision vers le plein
emploi une ambition dont les réformes
restent tout à fait pragmatique
cohérente pour aller vers la croissance
Emmanuel Macron lui a été chahuté par
les patrons qui sans lui être hostile
attendent des clarifications sur son
programme la première mesure que vous
allez prendre en tant que président de
la République si vous êtes élu
concrètement à quelle date ça va être
quoi pour nos entreprises la première
mesure ce sera la réforme du droit du
travail la réforme du droit du travail
mais ça va vous prendre un temps infini
c'est videré un étan avec une petite
cuillère quant à Jacques Cheminade
pierre Gatas n'y est pas allé par quatre
chemins si le candidat est sympathique
son programme économique n'est pas du
tout cohérent ni crédible
et première invité de notre multiplex
Alain houper sénateur LR de la Côte d'Or
il est à votre micro Tam oui Alain ouper
je voudrais d'abord vous faire réagir à
ce qu'a pu dire Emmanuel Macron cet
après-midi il est sûr d'avoir une
majorité au législative il veut
également complètement renouveler la vie
politique avec une moitié de candidats
issus de la société
civile et bien je suis admiratif devant
les gens qui ont des certitudes les CER
attitude s'amène toujours souvent dans
le mur et on le voit dans cette campagne
hein peut-être que celui qui a le plus
de solitude risque de perdre donc je ne
pense pas que Monsieur Macron puisse
être dans cette perspective de ralliment
parce que s'il est élu s'il est élu il
sera élu par défaut par
dépit par défiance et il y aura un
troisème tour qui sera celui des
législatives
ou les citoyens français à qui on
a ravi de
l'élection voteront pour un programme de
redressement national avec et je pense
que ça sera celui des républicains on va
également parler bien sûr de la droite
de sa situation comment jugez-vous la
stratégie de défense de François Fillon
le cabinet noir s'ans prendre à
l'exécutif estimer qu'il y a un un
complot à son
encontre il y a des campagnes qui sont
exaltante dans laquelle dans lesquelles
on a envie de s'élever dans lesquelles
on a envie de prendre le pou du
territoire dans lesqueles on avait envie
de réfléchir ensemble à des stratégies à
l'avenir ce n'est pas le cas parce que
cette campagne elle est nausé àond
abonde parce que on montre des hommes on
montre des ralliments mais on ne parle
pas vraiment des problèmes des Français
et le problème des Français c'est 6
millions de chômeurs et actuellement on
est en train de négocier euh les
allocations chômag on n' parle pas on
parle pas de la sécurité on parle pas de
l'immigration et sur cette stratégie
s'en prendre à l'exécutif et d'estimer
qu'il est visé par un complot je pense
que c'est c'est une erreur de de de se
mettre en victime parce qu'en
communication c'est ce qu'on appelle le
triangle de Capman persécuteur Sauveur
victime il faut jamais être dans ce
genre de de de situation parce que
automatiquement le candidat qui est dans
cette situation se met dans les cordes
et j'ai le sentiment de
l'impression de voir un candidat qui est
dans les cornes dans impossible de
remonter selon vous le classement et de
pouvoir se classer 2e lui qui est
aujourd'hui bon 3e derrière Emmanuel
Macron et Marine Le Pen c'est ce que
j'espère pour lui mais je suis un homme
de terrain comme je vous l'ai souvent
dit je suis un homme qui au contact un
homme qui aime l'intimité et qui aime le
relationnel en tant que médecin et
j'entends j'écoute
j'entends beaucoup de
déception face à des attitudes face à un
manque de probité c'est ce que mon
prédécesseur madame la sénatrice a dit
tout à l'heure c'est ce qu'on entend ce
manque de probité sur toutes dans tous
les territoires de France et je pense
qu'il y aura il y aura une sanction il y
aura une sanction qui va être prolongé
par l'élection d'un président par défaut
et des sanctions pour moral
la vie politique merci beaucoup Alain
hperre d'avoir répondu à nos questions
merci merci beaucoup Tam pour cette
réaction Emmanuel Macron justement en
quête d'une majorité parlementaire il a
présenté ses propositions pour moraliser
renouveler la politique pour lui les
investitures des candidats en marche
pour les législatives se feront par
vague successives d'ici au lendemain du
second tour de la présidentielle
Géraldine
bavoilo avec 25 jours de l'élection
présidentielle Emmanuel Macron est venu
convaincre qu'il dispose d'une majorité
parlementaire quand le candidat du Parti
socialiste est soutenu du bout des
lèvres par la majorité des siens quand
le candidat des républicains fait
campagne sans ses compétiteurs de la
primaire qui ont déserté le champ de
bataille la question de la majorité ne
se pose pas à nous elle se pose à ceux
qui voi leur soutien se réduire comme
pot de chagrin elle se pose à ceux qui
ont des frondur avant même les élections
législatives permettez-moi tout d'abord
dès la semaine prochaine son parti va
investir 577 candidats
estser chacun de nos candidats sera
investi sous la bannière de la majorité
présidentielle et non d'une étiquette
ancienne et devra se rattacher
politiquement et administrativement à
cette majorité ce ne sera pas une
majorité de st ni la réunion de
minorités ayant chacune leur agenda ce
sera une majorité d'efficacité
Emmanuel Macron promet que parmi les
élus une personne sur deux sera issue de
la société civile et la moitié sera
composé de femmes le candidat précise
aussi que ceux qui auront déjà été
déclarés inéligibles ne pourront pas
faire partie des troupes d' marche
désormais la priorité du candidat est de
convaincre les pour de français encore
indécis le pneumologue Michel Auer va
être jugé en juin par le tribunal
correctionnel de Paris en 2015 il avait
menti sous serment devant une commission
d'enquête du Sénat sur la pollution il
avait omis de déclarer ses liens avec
l'industrie pétrolière il risque jusqu'à
5 ans d'emprisonnement et 75000 €
d'amende la présidence du Sénat avait
signalé son cas à la justice en avril
2016 on va tout de suite écouter la
réaction de la sénatrice iste Corine
bouchou elle était au micro de Tam
tranui c'était il y a quelques instants
oui Corine bouchou est-ce une bonne
chose que Michel Auer comparaisse devant
le tribunal correctionnel au mois de
juin à la suite de cette omission sur
ses liens avec Total devant la
commission d'enquête du Sénat ben
écoutez euh je pense que c'est une bonne
chose je voulais au passage saluer le
travail de la sénatrice lelai puisque
c'est lors de cette commission d'enquête
que cette omission ou ce nom dit avait
été constaté je rappelle que le bureau
du Sénat avait été très clair c'est
peut-être d'ailleurs une première me
semble première depuis 1958 voilà donc
c'est une c'est une bonne chose ensuite
moi je me réjouis du fait que la justice
a fait son travail et donc je ne vais
pas j'allais dire commenter une décision
qui n'est pas intervenue mais je pense
que c'est bien que ce monsieur puisse
s'expliquer et donc qu'il puisse soit
montrer qu'il n'avait pas compris ce qui
est un conflit d'intérêt ce qui est une
hypothèse ou bien qu'il avait
délibérément omis de signaler des
activités non négligeables si regarde la
rémunération qui est en question ça
intervient aussi dans un contexte où la
moralisation devient un impératif de
plus en plus important dans la vie
politique et dans la vie publique de
façon plus large bien écoutez c'est un
vrai sujet moi je ne peux pas faire un
déplacement ou un marché sans que une
personne ne m'acoste en me parlant
effectivement de probité de respect de
la morale de respect de la déontologie
donc après il y a la question de
qu'est-ce qui est légal qu'est-ce qui
est illégal mais je pense que c'est
trèsnet il faut entendre le message nos
concitoyens cityens en ont assez d'un
certain nombre d'usages et de
dysfonctionnement ils le manifeste sous
diverses formes est-ce que ça n monre
pas aussi qu'il faut peut-être un peu
mieux vérifier les interlocuteurs qui
sont vus lors des commissions d'enquête
finalement c'était sorti mais un an plus
tard à travers un article du Canard
Enchaîné mais la commission d'enquête
ignorait ces liens écoutez c'est une
très bonne question c'est-à-dire quels
sont les moyens mis à disposition lors
d'une commission d'enquête et donc
est-ce que on fait un système à
l'américaine avec système de
questionnaire je crois d'une vingtaine
de pages avant chaque audition de chaque
personne je pense que on peut toujours
s'améliorer effectivement cette cet
événement montre que nous devons pour
nos commissions d'enquête être
extrêmement vigilant et que
malheureusement il y a des des abus
parfois oui une toute dernière question
politique vous avez parrainé benoî
Hamont comment est-ce que vous réagissez
à l'attitude de Manuel Vals qui a refusé
de le soutenir après la primaire et qui
aujourd'hui et bien rassemble autour de
lui des personnes on ne sait pas
peut-être pour préparer un soutien
Emmanuel Macron bon écoutez moi ça n'est
pas mon genre de donner des leçons aux
uns ou aux autres fustil ancien Premier
ministre après la question que j'ai
juste envie de poser c'est est-ce qu'il
n'y avait pas une charte de la primaire
est-ce que tous ceux qui ont participé
ne s'engageaient pas à soutenir le
premier il me semblait qu'il y avait
quelque chose de cet ordre et en tout
cas moi je respecte chaque position mais
nos concitoyens ne supportent plus ce
manquement à la parole donnée c'est ce
qui va tuer la démocratie merci beaucoup
Corine bechou d'avoir répondu à nos
questions merci beaucoup th pénéope
Fillon convoqué à son tour par les juges
d'instruction les enquêteurs cherchent à
déterminer si le nombre d'heures déclaré
pour son emploi à la revue des demandes
a été minimisé afin de respecter la
réglementation légale sur le cumul
d'emploi explication monounir souci
pénéope Fillon seule face au juge elle
devait être auditionnée aujourd'hui par
les magistrats en charge de l'enquête
contrairement à son époux elle aurait
accepté de répondre à leurs questions
dans les locaux du Pôle financier du
tribunal de grand en instance de Paris
elle fait face à trois motifs de mise en
examen d'abord pour recelle de
détournement de fonds publics pendant
son travail d'assistante parlementaire
un emploi présumé fictif entre 1986 et
2013 elle a touché 680000 € nets pour
cette mission ensuite la justice
soupçonne un recelle d'abus de biens
sociaux lors de sa collaboration à la
revue des de mondes où elle a publié
deux notes de lecture en 20 mois elle AP
perçu 5000 € brut mensuel pour 14 heures
de travail déclaré enfin le décompte de
ces heures de travail est au cœur du trè
motif de mise en examen pour recell
d'escroqueré aggravé et de faux et usage
de faux les enquêteurs questionnent
l'authenticité de documents saisis lors
d'une perquisition du bureau de député
de François Fillon il soupçonne le
couple d'avoir minimisé le nombre
d'heures de Pénélope Fillon à la revue
des demandes afin de ne pas en frin de
le règlement de l'Assemblée nationale
qui limite à 180 he par mois le cumul
d'emploi pour ses
salariés et on ouvre le premier débat de
présidentiel 360 et on va s'intéresser
ce soir à ces affaires qui sortent en
période électorale avec mes invités sur
ce plateau Benoît Bringer bonsoir vous
êtes journaliste d'investigation pour
l'agence première ligne vous travaillez
notamment pour l'émission cash
investigation vous êtes également membre
de lycée IGI c'est le consortium
international pour le journalisme
d'investigation vous avez travaillé sur
les Panama papers merci d'être avec nous
face à vous Benjamin Blancher bonsoir
vous êtes chargé de mission à l'USM
c'est l'Union Syndicale des Magistrats
merci d'être sur ce plateau première
question pour vous Benoît Bringer est-ce
que vous avez le sentiment que cette
période électorale est propice justement
à la sortie des affaires est-ce que les
gens se livre davantage selon vous alors
je pense que les journalistes cherchent
plus c'est ce qui est assez normal
puisqu'on est en campagne électorale on
doit faire un choix on dit souvent en
France que la présidentielle c'est la
rencontre d'un homme et des Français
donc on a besoin d'être informé euh sur
euh les hommes pour lequel on on on va
voter les les hommes ou les femmes
d'ailleurs euh il se trouve que en plus
euh on parle beaucoup de de François
Fillon évidemment il a eu des
engagements très forts pendant la
primaire sur l'exemplarité sur la
probité des hommes politiques donc c'est
assez logique que des journalistes
vérifient s'il y a une adéquation entre
ce que disent les hommes publics
et leur fait et ce qu'ils ont fait par
le passé question pour vous à présent
Benjamin Blancher comment toutes ces
révélations finalement arrivent-elles
aux journalistes est-ce qu'il y a des
fuites et si oui d'où viennent-elles
selon vous ça c'est très difficile à
dire voir impossible puisque vous savez
que les sources des journalistes sont
protégés heureusement d'ailleurs puisque
ça découle aussi de la convention
européne des droits de l'homme donc
c'est un droit qui est fondamental pour
les journalistes c'est aussi
l'exercice de la démocratie de la
liberté de l'opinion et donc c'est une
question que vous pourriez poser à des
journalistes mais vous n'auriez pas de
réponse et dans les affaires sensibles
on c'est que les informations remontent
à la Chancellerie qui a accès est-ce que
le pouvoir politique par exemple peut
avoir accès à certaines pièces alors
vous avez effectivement des rapports
d'information qui sont rédigés par les
procureurs qui sont transmis au parquets
généraux et ensuite les parquets
généraux informment à leur tour la
direction des affaires criminelles et
des grâces au ministère de la justice
mais d'une part ces remontées
d'informations ont sensiblement diminué
depuis
2013 puisqu'on est passé environ 12500 à
7500 à l'instant où je vous parle et ces
éléments ne doivent absolument pas
donner lieu à d'instruction individuelle
de la part du garde des saau dans les
dossiers qui auraient une connotation
politique h et on a beaucoup entendu ces
derniers jours cette expression de
cabinet noir hein c'est la ligne
d'attaque choisie par François Fillon
qu'en pensez-vous Boin Branger je pense
que c'est logique et c'est pas très
original comme stratégie de défense
d'attaquer le messager d'attaquer ceux
qui apporortent des informations en
l'occurrence a été les journalistes
d'attaqué également la justice moi je
pense que c'est la mauvaise question
parce
que les sources les informations elles
viennent de partout elles peuvent venir
d'autorité publique ell peuvent venir de
lanceurs d'alerte de gens qui sont dans
des entreprises qui ont accès à des
données elle peut venir de la justice
certainement du pouvoir politique
l'important c'est que disent ces
informations et c'est ça qui qui qui est
qui est le plus important finalement
même l'intention moi quand j'ai
quelqu'un qui vient me voir qui me donne
une information qui est d'utilité
publique qui a intérêt à être dans le
débat
général de une information d'intérêt
général finalement l'intention de la
personne m'importe peu il faut pas que
je me fasse manipuler c'est ça
l'essentiel bien sûr avoir un désir
d'orientation justement d'une enquête
d'un journaliste dans période
électorale possible mais la question
c'est est-ce que cette information est
utile au débat public voilà
si des personnes d'un cabinet noir
avaiit mise en place des rémunérations
un peu excessives pour P fill si c'est
confirmé là on serait dans une
manipulation mais les fait à la base
c'est ça qui importe et c'est là-dessus
qu' vous qu'il faut se pencher là on
voit bien qu'il y a une tentative de
diversion qui fonctionne parce que je
pense que on se dit c'est vrai d'où ça
vient ces informations on a une
curiosité les Français une curiosité
c'est normal et donc finalement on voit
que le débat prend sur cette question du
cabinet noir qui est à mon sens pas la
la question principale Françis hande
n'est pas candidat à l' élection
présidentielle Benjamin Blanchet est-ce
que on peut déjà orienter une
instruction est-ce qu'il peut y avoir et
bien des interférences de la part des
cabinets ministériels est-ce qu'ils
peuvent influencer une enquête selon
vous non non parce que la loi al c'est
récent CER mais une loi de juillet 2013
donc interdit ces instructions
individuelles donc si elles étaient
données elles seraient illégales avant
il y avait une possibilité d'ordre de
poursuite mais cet ordre de poursuite
devait être écrit et versé au dossier
donc il apparaissait tout de même alors
après certes il y a toujours le fantasme
du coup de téléphone donné directement
un procureur général ou un procureur de
la République ça relève du fantasme par
le oui ça relève du fantasme parce que
les
magistrats répondent à une déontologie
ils ont prêté un serment avant de
commencer leur fonction et ce type
d'intervention serait de toute façon
très très mal vécu et je ne pense même
pas compte tenu justement de l'intensité
du travail journalistique que nous
connaissons actuellement qu'elle
pourrait rester secrète donc elle se
retournerait très rapidement contre son
auteur benoî bring que selon vous il
faut une trêve en période électorale
surtout pas non je veux dire la trêve et
l'anomalie qu'on a vécu jusqu'à présent
il y a pas de raison par exemple que
Marine Le Pen ne soit pas entendue par
les juges alors même qu'elle est
présidente à l'élection présidentielle
qu'elle se présente au suffrage des
Français on doit les Français doivent
être informés et doivent avoir un vote
en toute connaissance de cause donc je
pense que au contraire l'anomalie et
l'immunité dont les hommes politiques
peuvent bénéficier voilà c'est ça ne met
pas en cause
la politique d'un pays on n'est pas sur
des questions stratégiques extrêmement
graves c'est normal qu'on soit informé à
mon avis à mon sens la trêve ne se
justifie pas du tout Benjamin Blancher
on a vu un des élus LR qui demande
l'ouverture d'une enquête judiciaire sur
des pratiques présumées illégale de
l'Élysée est-ce qu'on peut bien
justement mener une enquête sur l'Élysée
bah mener une enquête sur l'Élysée non
parce qu'il faut composer avec
l'immunité présidentielle qui a le
statut protecteur du chef de l'État
absolument qui est conféré par la
constitution on peut pas non plus
perquisitionner à l'Élysée parce que
l'Élysée est considéré comme une
enceinte militaire qui bénéficie de
cette immunité et euh donc il y a des
restrictions cela étant les
collaborateurs les membres du cabinet du
présidents de la République ne
bénéficient pas de cette immunité les
haut-fonctionnaires les ministres non
plus mais euh est-ce qu'il y a eu des C
où la justice parfois c'est interdite de
juger des affaires en temps d'élection
non pas véritablement il y a il y a pu
avoir mais de manière tout à fait
sporadique ce qu'on appelle des renvois
où on a tenu des audiences après la date
prévue parce que l'affaire était d'un
retentissement tout à fait moyen et au
contraire il aurait été sans
doute contre-productif d'évoquer cette
affaire alors qu'elle n'avait pas
véritablement connotation politique de
nature influé sur sur un scrutin donc
c'était plutôt pour éviter une
désinformation et et une injustice
électorale que on a pu programmer une
audience après une élection mais jamais
un tribunal c'est interdit d'évoquer une
affaire tout simplement parce que il y
avait de haut personnages politiques qui
étaient impliqués dans celle-ci ouais
est-ce que ça peut faire le jeu du Front
national c'est ce qu'on entend aussi
Benoît Bringer bien la révélation de ses
affaires je pense qu'il faut
différencier aussi la révélation des
affaires qui à mon sens doivent être
dans le dans le débat public par la
presse j'entends oui bien sûr qui qui
grâce à la presse peuvent être dans le
débat public et une petite musique qu'on
entend constamment parce que on a des
commentaires sur des chaînes d'infoue en
permanence là-dessus c'està-dire qu'on
l'entend du début à la fin auun moment
il y a une saturation de l'opinion
publique et assez légitime parce que
d'ailleurs on peut sortir d'importe
quelle information maintenant sur
François Fillon je pense que c'est la
guerre plus d'impact que ce qui a eu
lieu déjà donc au bout d'un moment
effectivement il y a une saturation et
ça ça peut faire effectivement donner un
un sentiment d'goût mais je pense que ce
qui fait vraiment le jeu du Front
national c'est le sentiment d'un unité
qu'on en revanche les hommes politiques
les puissants et le fait qu'ils soi pas
des des des justiciables comme les
autres ça en revanche c'est beaucoup
plus grave je pense et et là on on n'est
pas sur ce au contraire on est sur
l'exemple inverse ou on évoquit la
protection des des sources pour les
journaliste comment réagissez-vous quand
vous voyez certains PV d'enquêtte publié
dans la presse est-ce que cela vous
surprend par exemple Benjamin Blancher
ça ne me surprend non ça ne surend pas
parce que voilà c'est une pratique
maintenant qui est devenue assez
courante mais il faut quand même
rappeler que c'est contraire à la loi
puisque l'instruction est protégée par
la loi s'agissant de sa confidentialité
le fait de divulguer ce type
d'information c'est pass possible de
sanction pénale puisque ça peut
constituer l'infraction de violation du
secret professionnel pour la personne
qui le reçoit de recelle de violation du
secret professionnel mais il faut bien
reconnaître que c'est une réalité cette
réalité encore une fois est illégale
mais euh l'actualité nous montre que
maintenant c'est une pratique devenue
tellement courante que il est sans doute
difficile de l'endiguer mais encore une
fois je pense que les journalistes
seraientê secret de l'instruction
finalement Benjamin Blanchet ça n'existe
plus le secret de l'instruction ça
n'existe plus ça existe dans le code de
procédure pénale ça c'est une certitude
dans les fait on doit assister à son
dépérissement réel ça c'est une
certitude sur il faut savoir qu'il y a
effectivement le secret de l'instruction
et puis a le droit à l'information
également donc effectivement souvent le
juge est amené à estimer est-ce qu'on on
est dans le droit de l'information ou
pas euh bon avec le secret des sources
c'est difficile de poursuivre un
journaliste pour pour violation du
secret de l'instruction alors peut-être
qu'on pourrait se pencher sur le terme
de recel mais je suis pas sûr qu'il y a
eu déjà des condamnations ou en tout cas
beaucoup de condamnations effectivement
nous ce qu'on met en balance c'est
l'information du public voilà est-ce
qu'on est sur une affaire suffisamment
importante pour nécessiter d'aller sur
la place publique avec des preuves parce
que c'est extrêmement difficile de
donner uneination sans preuve et c'est
vrai que les pièces même si moi je
travaille pas beaucoup sur des pièces
judiciaires c'est vrai que les pièges
judiciaires sont des éléments évidemment
de de des éléments de preuve ou en tout
cas des des documents qui ont une
certaine importance Benjamin Blanché on
a parlé d'une selle campagne d'une
campagne pourrie par les affaires est-ce
qu'il y aura un avant et un après cette
campagne pour la présidentielle est-ce
que ça va impacter peut-être les
méthodes de travail à la fois de la
justice mais aussi peut-être des
journalistes d'investigation selon vous
probablement je pense en tout cas que
s'agissant de l'institution judiciaire
elle a connu la crise la plus grave des
30 dernières années compte tenu de la VI
violence des attaques qui ont été
portées contre elle par certains hommes
politiques cela étant elle va continuer
de faire son travail sans doute de
manière encore plus approfondie parce
que les magistrats se spécialisent et
ils
devront avant l'élection présidentielle
pendant après travailler avec la même
intensité pour une raison simple c'est
qu'ils sont indépendants très rapidement
B et puis on est après c'est la première
élection présidentielle poste Cahusac
postcandal Cusac et après la création du
parquet national financier voilà et
c'est une une un parquet qui est qui est
qui est nouveau et effectivement on voit
la différence en tout cas c'est c'est un
parquet qui a la volonté d'agir vite et
je pense que la procureur Ilan Noulette
quel que soient les personnes concernées
que ça soit François Fillon ou encore
Bruno lerou Brou voil effectivement donc
je pense que ça aussi ça marque une
différence merci beaucoup bonoît Bringer
merci Benjamin Blanché d'être venu sur
ce plateau c'est la fin de cette édition
tout de suite les preuve de vérité qui
reçoit ce soir le président du BEM
François beayou qui qui soutient je vous
le rappelle Emmanuel Macron bonne soirée
à
[Musique]
tous